let's go where are we going next
let's go to uh let's go to
katherine gg i don't know what if that's
a location what is gg
catherine is that a where you are
hello yes hello hi
yes i'm from arkansas but i go to
college in tulsa oklahoma
oh okay very good um so i've got a
question about
trump's upcoming cpac speech
yes so i i know there's going to be like
some
news that kind of he might uh announce
his 2024 candidacy
like i honestly don't care about that i
don't
care what he has to say about like 2022
either because you know with the ongoing
legal investigation something might
happen before right
but what i'm most what what i'm worried
about
is like if he's gonna say anything about
the supreme court ruling on his tax
returns
um i know he's already re i know he's
already had a statement
in response to that but um
well what are you what are you worried
about like what would he say that
worries you
like i like i don't know like he could
probably like be spreading some
while like like i know this is
hypothetical
it's over exaggerated but you know like
how predictable is he
honestly you know like he's always got
targets such as the media and the
democrats and like
you know like the the court system like
he like he thinks everything is rigged
against him
like do you think he could like start
spreading conspiracies about
how unfair the court system could be oh
it wouldn't be that he starts i mean
anytime a court has ruled against him he
either you know i mean it goes back to
attacking that judge
um in 2017 and saying the judge couldn't
couldn't fairly rule because his parents
are mexican
so tr of course trump will do that i
just don't think that it's a particular
concern i mean he's an ex-president yes
he's going to speak at cpac on sunday
i think the most impactful thing he
could do would be to announce his 2024
candidacy he'll probably rail against
who knows who for treating him unfairly
i think at this point we all expect it i
don't think it'll have much of an impact
okay well i i'm just curious because you
know like
if these legal investigations like if
something does really come up like he is
convicted
and possibly sent to um
prison for whatever charges are entailed
it's not gonna happen
uh well like well what about like his
followers in the case that something
like that happened
like what would they do trump trump's
just not going to prison i mean i don't
know that it
even is worth hypothesizing
okay all right sorry if that's like an
over-exaggerated or
hypothetical thing but no no i mean it's
good it's good to think about these
things just the us doesn't jail
past presidents and i just don't uh you
know people have asked that off and on
for the last year i don't think it's
going to happen
okay all right well thanks for reaching
out david
yeah thanks catherine very much
appreciate the call catherine
from arkansas in tulsa very very
exciting
you may not have known this but when you
see me sitting here on the show
i am often wearing shirts by a company
called teddy stratford i asked them to
be a sponsor because they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button-up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden underneath the buttons which
actually prevents the chest from looking
weird and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100
egyptian cotton and flat-felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman
at checkout